investors what do they want a dress
today there's so many issues here with
MX there are it's an important day for
American Express and its shareholders as
you said there's been a string of bad
news from the company the past few
months and really today is the day that
investors want to hear specifics about
how the company is going to recover from
losses around the loss of their costco
relationship their jet blue relationship
as well as the antitrust lawsuit that
you mentioned so it's specifics around
how to address those things and they
also want to hear reassurance that some
of the the recent setbacks that have
come out aren't indicative of bigger
problems at the company okay there's
four things you say and I think you
touched upon some of them but just
outline for us Elizabeth the four things
he needs to address sure I'm so one of
the first ones is American Express has
been for a while now falling back on
some of its own growth goals
specifically revenue growth and so
particularly that's something that
investors want to hear more specifics
about in light of the fact that you know
the costco which is one of their biggest
retail partnerships twenty percent of
their loans eight percent of spendings
one out of every ten cards you know as
that you know potentially goes away over
the next year you know how that kind of
factors in in terms of you know broader
financial goals that the company hopes
to achieve okay so that's one of them
okay one of the real estate goals guys
bring that back up please better rewards
is is the second goal here lower costs
and wider acceptance uh yeah wider
acceptance meaning what so American
Express is accepted at fewer stores than
cards that are run on visa and
mastercard networks and for the most
part American Express charges merchants
a higher rate and that is something that
they have been trying to address and
particularly this time last year they
announced a program where they are going
to be trying to sign up more small
businesses across the country here in
the US to accept their cards and so
that's something that a lot of investors
are eager to hear an update on it's been
a year now and sort of its
general attention on american express
his relationship with merchants has come
into focus particularly in the in the
past few weeks after they lost this
critical antitrust lawsuit that could
threaten you know there are long-term
business model in terms of how they can
charge merchants higher rates